[music playing]
EMILY WATSON: Hi,
I'm Emily Watson.
I play Elsa Einstein, a genius.
Please don't.
This is the third time I've
played Mrs. Geoffrey Rush.
And we actually have a really
nice working relationship.
We just have that sense of
feeling comfortable together,
and we have a
physical familiarity.
What I've really enjoyed
is the fact that Jeffrey
and I look quite similar.
We've both got these
kind of crazy gray wigs.
And we're playing people
who've got to the stage
where they just don't care.
And that's really fun.
When we were preparing, I
said, Geoffrey, I just--
I think we're going
to have to play them
as Tweedledum and Tweedledee.
Almost twins, in a way.
And, background action!
Watching the coffin.
EMILY WATSON: Here
comes the coffin.
EMILY WATSON: I had such a
lovely time working with Ron.
Einstein!
Like
There's Einstein.
Einstein.
EMILY WATSON: He's such
a legend, isn't he?
He's so clear and strong
and the way that he finds
that rhythm of storytelling.
Albert!
GEOFFREY RUSH: If
we leave, they win.
EMILY WATSON: It's
just really exciting.
The idea of this man,
sort of really on his own,
without what our sense of
what a modern scientific realm
is, making these
immense discoveries.
But also, being sort of right
at the center of history
as the 20th century unfolds.
Cutting.
Checking.
EMILY WATSON: Yeah, I
find it quite exciting.
I hope that's what
people get from it.